et vous le connaissez c'est le maire de
wettolsheim lucien muller comment allez
vous merci bonsoir très bien on est
ravis de vous accueillir vous êtes
conseiller départemental également dans
le canton de wintzenheim votre binôme
c'est monique martin ça se passe bien
avec monique à ça se passe très bien
avec monique les loups verts et après je
pourrai un reportage que vous avez c'est
un très bon binôme eh ben on va le voir
dessus puisque adrien on l'a pas envoyé
boire les meilleurs vins qui a dans
votre compte ni manger du master on lui
a simplement demandé de voir un petit
peu l'excellence qui via sur le travail
que vous faites au quotidien avec
notamment une crèche modèle des
aménagements le long des cours d'eau et
un réseau routier regarde tous les tours
du world tour sept ans les queens and
i'm sure c'est coton sur un col
quelques-uns des nectars qui font le
monde entier la renommée de notre région
haut lieu de la gastronomie le canton
c'est aussi la vallée de munster
nul besoin de préciser quel fut son
apport au patrimoine alsacien
autant de bonnes choses ne pourraient
voir le jour sans un milieu naturel
protégé dans la vallée le département
intervient dans la gestion des cours
d'eau
objectif la sécurité des habitants en
cas de crue la protection des espèces
aquatiques mais aussi développer le
tourisme vert à la vallée de munster aux
nouveaux emplois et aux grosses
entreprises main disons c'est
relativement sinistrés
par contre en ce qui concerne le
tourisme c'est vraiment à développer et
donc il faut être attractif et en
favorisant les déplacements doux en
favorisant
les promenades les randonnées dans un
cadre agréable ça qu'au théâtre
c'est vrai que c'est sympa
axe de communication majeur du canton la
rn83 qui relie colmar
près de rouffach un nouvel échangeur sur
l'a35 assurera sa connexion avec
l'autoroute
cette petite ligne
transversales reliant les deux routes la
problématique routière c'est
effectivement l'augmentation de la
circulation qui risque de doubler par
rapport à l'utilisation donc de cette
route
il s'agit de sécuriser la traversée pour
que les riverains qui sont donc habitués
ici sur cette zone puisse en toute
sécurité
rentrer et sortir de chez eux
département également prévu une
enveloppe pour que les riverains
puissent changer leurs fenêtres pour
être préservée du bruit nous sommes deux
multi accueil pomme de reinette ici ce
sont 77 enfants de logelbach et
wintzenheim qui sont accueillis chaque
semaine nous avons une population il
comprend deux jeunes ménages se sont
donc à la fois des personnes qui
travaillent mais également des personnes
qui sont à la recherche non pas qu'ils
ont besoin d'un créneau horaire libre où
la garde des enfants est assuré de
philosophie du lieu il doit s'adapter à
l'enfant l'environnement est en partie
intégrante de l'éducation les petits en
2011 l'accueil a été rénové dans l'idée
d'en faire un pôle d'excellence
le conseil départemental a participé la
hauteur de 110 mille euros le
département estime la compétence la
petite enfance par les services de la
pmi qui effectivement assure une aide de
conseils et de contrôle il ya également
au niveau de ses structures d'accueil un
rôle social pour des enfants en
difficulté des enfants porteurs
d'handicap donc c'est également une
compétence du conseil de partout ici les
petits sont choyés et chouchoutés on en
aurait presque envie de retourner en
enfance
voilà on a fait un petit peu le tour du
canton lucien on l'a vu aussi un master
bonvin haut lieu de la gastronomie est
ce que ces symboles as suffisent à faire
vivre le territoire
bien sûr que non mais sur ce territoire
ont bien on produit bien d'autres choses
mais même ça va vous étonner peut-être
de l'eau on
aux deux bouts du territoire ont produit
de l'eau naturelle ce qui est également
très important le vin bien sûr mais avec
toute l'économie qui l'accompagnent les
entreprises aussi de son style ya des
belles entreprises au niveau de la
bureautique au niveau 2 des pièces
automobiles aussi et léger utilisant un
bon réseau de pme et pmi jugement
puisqu'on parle d'entreprises et quels
sont les outils dont vous disposez pour
soutenir des entreprises vous vous dites
toujours le social c'est l'économie oui
le social c'est l'économie alors déjà en
préambule je voudrais juste dire très
rapidement je sais que au niveau de la
loi de notre le département n'a plus la
compétence économie mais si on ne fait
pas ce qu'il faut au niveau de
l'économie on va forcément augmenter le
budget social alors l'action du
département
ces emplois emplois l'action du
c'est également à travers une agence le
car qui aujourd'hui a fusionné avec la
dir est attractive et également au
niveau du tourisme donc une agence d de
développement du tourisme est également
à la paille qui est les entreprises donc
à acheter les terrains donc au niveau
financier que le fait de préciser que
les agences économiques et touristiques
maintenant au fusionner bas rhin haut
rhin une partie de votre canton et dans
les rues rebelles de colmar c'est un
véritable avantage alors il ya des
avantages et des inconvénients
effectivement mon canton il enfin de mon
canton notre canton il est si vaste que
on a des parties ce que les gens
définissent plutôt des ruraux et des
périurbains alors au niveau des
périurbains
il ya sûrement des avantages la
proximité de tous les services que ce
soit au niveau des loisirs que ce soit
au niveau médecine les hôpitaux les
spécialistes c'est la ville mais l'autre
inconvénient il est en premier pour les
élus parce que les gens même s'ils
viennent entre guillemets à la campagne
pour chercher le calme et
la tranquillité il attend toujours les
services de la ville puisqu'ils sont
habitués aux services de la ville et
c'est quelque chose qui est difficile à
gérer
et puis après vous connaissez tous les
histoires de coke de deux tracteurs donc
ils font du bruit tôt le matin enfin bon
et les problèmes il faut considérer deux
alors sur la ville de munster le
département est propriétaire de quatre
barrages les barrages ça fait pas partie
de vos compétences en principe les
barrages ça fait pas partie de nos
compétences si on veut mais c'est des
bars des barrages qui appartiennent au
département
c'est là qu'ils appartiennent au
département et donc le département les
entretiens complètement et pour gérer la
rivière donc la flèche puisqu'on parle
de la vallée de munster
il ya un syndicat mixte que préside mme
obino monique martin qui a donc en
compte cette gestion de sites dont le
département pays également 70% des
travaux
quand vous ces images là vous êtes
vernis vous êtes quand même dans un
canton assez beau oui mais ce qu'on
attend c'est la remontée du saumon et ça
fait partie et et ça fait partie
également des objectifs de ce syndicat
mixte vous êtes un pêcheur par hasard à
6 et ben voilà on lui à léon dernière
question on l'a vu à master
l'environnement ça constitue un atout de
développement qu'est ce que vous faites
au quotidien pour l'environnement alors
au quotidien pour l'homme et
l'environnement le département est
également mis en place une action
originale pour la gestion et l'entretien
des territoires c'est à dire le gères
plan alors le gerb l'an i le gerland il
englobe également
premièrement les paysages tout ce qui
est hydro logis les rivières et la
conservation du biotope des animaux
l'agriculture aussi l'agriculture
raisonnée ainsi que les circuits courts
vous sortez des efforts un parent au
centre des efforts par tout à fait clair
voilà l'environnement c'est maintenant
une préoccupation après la communauté
après la coupure et a surtout mais je
pense que en alsace surtout aussi est
déjà pris depuis un moment
voilà
mais un pêcheur on est sensible à
l'environnement absolument mais on dit
encore autre chose des pêcheurs ça on ne
dira pas matin s'est fait un plaisir de
vous recevoir